für mein empfinden mit große
gewalttätigkeiten das heißt es denn
deutschland gemeinsam machen ist aber
keinen satz dieses gewusel nacht mit
[Musik]
das ist ein energie werbespot oder fünf
uhr jedoch besteht auf mein name ist
martin schmitt de ist die nicht martin
schmitt ich bin der mann
vater
und industrie mit ist es nun kein
gedanke ganz normales leben ich stehe
früh auf und sorge für meine kleine
familie
ich weiß normal klingt langweilig für
manche besonders für die experten im
fernsehen
das zu experten im fernsehen werden ja
auch meistens gefragt wenn nicht normale
dinge geschehen sowie fluten oder so
vielleicht aber werden irgendwann fluten
so normal dass wir gar keine expertin
jedenfalls wenn die idee ankommt könnte
das ja die neue normalität sein
normal ist für mich
etwas im argen
dass nicht immer nur einfache bürger
dran kommen
sondern mal wieder echte ganoven
kalt da nochmal zurückspulen das ja
bezaubernd das wird casino er weiß man
da weiß man wirklich
da ist der teufel direkt abgebildet ein
weißer
lisa weißer bmw vor dem wettkampf 4000
wir wissen ja web casino 4000 diese
berüchtigte ganoven kette
da habe ich auch schon viel geld
verloren
dass man die kleinen wieder beschützt
und damit die großen nicht immer größer
werden
und dass die regierung ist nicht nur
abkassiert wo es geht das springen
einfach mal wieder für uns funktion in
welcher welt leben die eigentlich all
das war doch mal normal in deutschland
als die politiker noch wussten für wen
sie da sind
sie da sind denn das bedeutet ja nur für
menschen wie den der dark alle zur
arbeit fährt und für alle anderen
vielleicht lieber nicht ehrlich wir
müssen mal was ändern
und ich denke
die zeit ist jetzt
jetzt geht es zu schnell deutschland
aber schön aber sicher aber normal
moment können wir das noch mal haben wir
das noch mal das kann man also schon
mitbringen aber schön aber sicher aber
stark aber normal bewegen wird geworben
sehen sie aber guck ich mein so blöd sie
nicht natürlich einsatz ist wie
deutschland aber normal hat er trotzdem
in sich natürlich eine eine ungeheure
bedrohlichkeit also jedenfalls empfinde
ich das so dass alles was uns in diesem
kurzen video nicht gezeigt wird auch wie
eigentlich jenseits des normalen liegt
und damit eben ausgegrenzt das schreibt
sich trotzdem wer in diesem land leben
möchte
ich weiß es nicht zu sagen
aber nochmal insofern finde ich diesen
sport unbrauchbar obwohl ich natürlich
im netz gesehen habe dass er
reichlich positive kommentare bekommt
für menschen die sich ebenfalls nach
einer deutschen normalität sehnen in der
nur bestimmte menschen von der politik
gemeint sind steuerlich